for dozens of families here in Balmoral
this is all they have left most of the
town was engulfed in a blaze so fierce
it created a firestorm this family
stayed to try and protect their home
while the inferno swept through their
property we had no chance we got smashed
the heat was seriously intense for one
of a better word I'm estimating that
it's probably hit a thousand two
thousand four degrees back here without
a house just days before Christmas
members of this family are being helped
by their neighbors but they're unsure of
what lies ahead the generosity of the
community as is with small communities
and everywhere else that just been
amazingly generous people that have
offered us homes and everything else
under the Sun to assist us this this
time really we don't have any plans at
this stage this community is a small one
home to just 400 Australians but it's
been devastated by this bushfire crisis
dozens of homes were lost this weekend
alone and more than a thousand houses
have been destroyed since the start of
the bushfire season this couple's
property is scorched but they still have
their house we were lucky to keep our
house very lucky and I know how lucky we
are and it was thanks to this man that
we don't we know if he wasn't here we
would have lost our house emergency
warnings are still in place and a heat
wave is expected to return in just a few
days but fire crews are making the most
of the cooler weather and that's allowed
some of those who evacuated to return
and assess the damage I said we're very
lucky and extremely grateful but some of
our neighbors but we all going to help
together that's what we're here for
were very close-knit community and we'll
get through this her house has escaped
the fires along with her Christmas
lights
Jessica Washington al-jazeera balmoral
Australia